-Jane, it's so lovely
to see you again. How are you?
-I'm very good, Seth.
How are you?
-I'm hanging in there.
Have your last few months
been okay?
-They haven't been
any different.
[ Laughs ]
-You're someone
who stays at home?
-Yeah, yeah. You know, we --
basically, we walk the dog
I cook all the time.
We don't have that
many restaurants around here
Well, we really have
no restaurants around here now
So our life
isn't that different.
-Do you have enough skill as
a chef to not sort of repeat
things over and over again
or is that alright?
-I've been cooking for 44 years.
Pretty much two,
if not three meals a day.
-Oh, well, there you go.
So you are ready then.
-I'm sick of it.
I'm so sick of it.
-Have you ever thought
about retiring?
Because my mother-in-law,
before I even met her, retired
Just woke up one day and said,
"I'm not doing it anymore.
-We'd starve.
-Yeah.
-There's no takeout, really,
to speak of, so...
We don't eat rabbit.
We have tons of rabbit.
-Yeah.
-The chipmunks ate my tomatoes
We'd starve.
-Yeah, yeah. Alright.
Well, that's good to know.
Your new show, "United We Fall,"
you play someone
who moves in with her son
and her grandchildren.
I mean, based on the way you'r
singing your praises as a chef
it seems like they would be very
happy if you moved in with them.
Yes? In real life.
-Well, in real life,
my daughter and her family
I think, would really
like me to move in.
I think that we'd all
have a good time.
I think that they'd like
my husband to move in, too
I think we'd all like
to live together.
It's sort of a --
We like each other.
-They warn you about -- they
warn you against, I should say
working with children.
How did you get along with
the children in your cast?
-Oh, I've always liked
working with kids.
I like kids a lot.
-Really?
-Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I like them.
I like working with kids.
I like working with dogs.
I love working with monkeys.
I really like
working with monkeys.
-Really? Monkeys is -- The few
times we had monkeys on the se
at "SNL," I was very uneasy.
But you enjoy it?
-Yeah, I find them fascinating
I worked with
a 2-year-old chimp once,
and my daughter was 2
at the same -- at this time.
And we were taking a break
and the chimp was playing
on the staircase.
And the chimp was playing
the same games
the 2-year-old plays.
It was so interesting to watch
We had a spider monkey
on "3rd Rock,"
and this guy was
just so well-trained.
And, you know,
he didn't want to play.
So his -- I was talking to
his trainer,
and his trainer said,
"So, you like monkeys?"
I said,
"Yeah, I like all animals.
And he said, "Have you ever me
an orangutan?"
I said, "No," and he said,
"Do you want to?"
And I went, "Yeah."
And he said, "Come with me."
So we went out to the traile
that the animals came in.
And he said, "Go on in."
And I walked in,
and there's an orangutan
sitting on a sofa
kind of like...
-[ Laughs ]
-And the guy said,
"Go on, sit next to him."
And I sort of went over
and I sat next to the orangutan.
And the orangutan
looked at me and went...
-[ Laughing ]
-It just hugged me.
-Oh, wow.
-It was just --
He just hugged me.
-That's as good an ending
you can hope for in a stor
where a guy tells you
to get into a truck
with a weird monkey.
[ Laughter ]
A lot of times
there's no orangutan in the van.
That's just --
-Oh, stop.
-That's when you realized
you've made a mistake.
I tell you, they go, "Go i
and look at the orangutan.
The next thing you know,
the van door closes.
That's the last
anybody ever sees of you.
-No, no, no, that's only
if it's a white panel truck.
-You're right. I'm sorry.
I've been misleading.
-Yes. Yeah.
-The last time we saw each other
was a really fun,
emotional night
because we were --
It was the "SNL 40th."
-Yeah.
-And we were at
the "Update" desk together
-Yeah.
-Everybody went back that night,
had to work through some stuff
to be back in 8H.
How was that for you?
-I had gone to a couple of
the rehearsals and --
because I like to get
a sense of place.
So I would go to the rehearsal
early and just sort of sit u
in the bleachers and get a fee
for what it was like
and what was going on
and what the vibe was.
And people would come up t
talk to me, which is --
people I had never met before,
which was just great.
Just so friendly.
And so I got a feel for it
It wasn't so scary.
The scary part of 8H
was getting out.
It was always getting out.
Because when we were there
there were crowds that would
you know, gather down below.
-Sure.
-And a couple of times,
you know,
we had cars to take us home,
and a couple of times, you know,
you'd be getting into the car,
and people would charge
and get into the car with you,
and you had no --
you know, you didn't know
how to deal with it.
So the driver would have to be
pulling these people out.
So there was this thing
about getting out
that was always the problem.
-I think that speaks to the fact
that obviously
the show is still
incredibly popular.
You know, I'd like to think it
was popular when I was there
but it was never quite
what it was...
-It was new.
-...when it first started.
Because, I mean, that -- like,
people banging on the car,
like what you're talking about
I think, is very unique
to that first cast
and the sort of institutio
that "SNL" was to New York
at the time.
-Yeah, yeah.
I mean, we were --
we were a phenomenon.
We were very sort of
rock and roll,
which was very attractive
and counterculture.
And television was changing.
I mean, just look at the way
we looked was different.
You didn't see people like tha
on television very often.
And, yeah,
so it was a phenomenon,
and people wanted a part of it
People wanted to be there.
People wanted to say, you know
"I was around the vibe.
I felt the energy."